you're very good actor no I really like
it when you when you act in movies and
and lately you've been you've been
called upon to do certain dialects like
an Appalachian or Georgian accent yeah
do you find that to be a challenge well
yeah I mean you know I am I kind of look
at it like I am white trash you're I
mean you believe you're white right and
a dried Jim you are white rum Indiana
and by the way I don't think that's
necessarily a derogatory term I think
you know I think white trash is a
derogatory or does it mean you have a
relative that cause cheddar cheese fancy
cheese but ya know like it doesn't feel
that foreign to put on a a Georgia
accent or you know Appalachian like it
feels like it's in your nature because
it feels a little it feels familiar you
know I come from the Rust Belt which is
you know kind of a cute fancy term for
economic devastation yeah I mean it's
you know and I am white but I'm like
Rust Belt white trash which is different
from rural or suburban white trash like
the first time I went fishing I'm not
making this up it was in the community
swimming pool every serious every
September they would fill the public
pool with fish and kids would try and
catch the fish where the chlorine killed
the fish Laurene in the water that was
like in the 70s yeah have you ever heard
of this Andy just when he tells about it
yeah I thought maybe you might have done
it no they would jewelry yeah you'd feel
a regular swimming pool that's
chlorinated why they didn't do it they
did it in the town yeah but then would
you what would you sit in a rowboat and
try and kick you know you would sit
around the pool and I think I was in the
town paper cuz I caught the most fish
most dead fish I don't think you could
eat the fish either no you can't cuz
that's terrible I know but this was this
was this the latest a not everything is
excused
it was the seventies it was Walker watch
those love votes those are terrible it
was this I murdered earlier in my life
we were all murdering yeah you posted a
photo cuz you talk a lot about food you
have certain obsessions with you photo
posted a photo of something you call a
garbage plate yes let's take a look at
this photograph this is real this is not
a stunt this is real you seem happy
where are you and what are you eating
what is the in Rochester New York every
you know like every city or area has
their food specialty and Rochester is
the home of the garbage plate and I
didn't realize how big it was like I
asked on Twitter where should I get a
garbage plate and there's like 12 places
but like if what's included in a garbage
plate is so hashbrowns cold macaroni
salad mm-hmm cold baked beans hotdog
which they call a hot and then a meat
sauce over it and I'm sure I'm getting
it wrong but it is like there's no
obviously there's no health department
in Rochester but it was it was delicious
and it was was it good it was good it's
weird how there's cold and hot so the
cold you're like do you guys think the
cold food is healthy or something is
that why it's called and then it was it
was no good how did you feel afterwards
I still haven't recovered really
it was it was pretty fascinating but
it's almost like you know like your
Rochester Minnesota is known for the
Mayo Clinic it's almost like Rochester
New York was like we're gonna create a
dish of food that causes cancer it gives
you instantly sister cities yeah yeah
and you had it you enjoyed I had it it
was great and I highly recommend it if
you go to Rochester you gotta check it
out
no no you say that but no you know like
even the macaroni the cold macaroni
salad I didn't even know people even
made that anymore like you see these
aren't things that recommend it you know
yeah I know you've got to have it why
cuz I didn't think it could be made I
didn't think that was post-its like I
was imagining the guy who invented it
was probably at a picnic and he filled
his plate up too much and his wife was
like oh my gosh you Pig what have you
done and he's like I created a garbage
play just took off from there